[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my my opening comment uh opening
question is just uh you know to describe
for us the genesis of the process or the
the project and maybe we could even back
up a little bit because um
i can't remember if fred told me or i
read it in one of the reviews out there
about the project but that he had met up
with uh another photographer in pursuing
this idea um that wasn't the best match
and then found mary beth who was the
perfect match and this spoke to a a
project that had really been in
development for some time at least in
fred's head and that it wasn't a product
of serendipity it was something that was
really sort of thought through in
advance so i was wondering if you tell
us like how it began and sort of evolved
fun to even to
to get us to the beginning of the
project absolutely
want me to jump on this one great i'll
start there so first off hi and i'll
speak both the people who are in the
room into the machine that represents
the people who aren't um it's really
nice to be here um thank you heather for
having us um i have taught in cms 20
years ago i taught in this program um i
also taught at the sloan school of
management this is home world for me and
i'm absolutely thrilled to be back a lot
of friends around the table and i'm
grateful so thank you um and i want to
say that this is very much a joint mary
beth and fred project and and really we
really cooked it up together i had been
bothered for a long time um by something
i'd seen in silicon valley mythology so
some of you will know i'm a historian of
silicon valley very much focused on the
myths that drive the valley and where
they come from one of the deepest myths
is that
technologists build systems that make
people transparent and that you know
through these systems you can just see
everyone and everyone's there we can
just quote connect everyone i loathe
that word but um you know what was what
was becoming clear to me though was that
the systems of connection that we were
building
did nothing to reveal the actual world
on the ground in which we live so i live
in mountain view about two miles from
google's headquarters i have a family i
raised a daughter there um i have a boy
who lived with us for a period of time
as well and i know a very different kind
of place and so i wanted very much to
see the valley
now seeing is really hard and that's
really mary beth's domain so um i was
very very lucky i a friend pointed me to
a couple of different photographers i
actually had one out who will go unnamed
um precisely because they lack all the
qualities that make mary beth and her
work so special
um you know
just plug your ears for a second okay
maybe i'll talk about her process but
it's
it's
i think that what mary beth has done in
her other work and she'll talk about her
other work is see people in places
where those places have for a variety of
historical reasons conspired to render
those folks less visible
and mary beth has a technique for seeing
for working with her subjects for making
them visible in a classical idiom of
portraiture of a kind usually reserved
for honoring those folks who are already
honored in society
and to do that work in silicon valley
seemed especially important now as it
turned out that when we began doing that
or
well yes thank you so much for having
having us it's so good to be at the
table and in the virtual world i'm not
exactly sure where we should where i
should look should i not think about
that
should i just look at the humans here
okay
um so thank you so much for having us um
uh yeah i got this call from out of the
blue
to go to stanford and to to think about
working in silicon valley and my kids
were pretty little it was 2017
and i thought silicon valley what do i
know about so what could i offer silicon
valley what am i going to do in silicon
valley and my little son said mom
can't just do what you always do just
walk around and talk to people
and i thought i suppose i could do that
there
and i too was feeling really um
hemmed in by this knit mythology i mean
silicon valley was i going to go knock
on mark zuckerberg's store i mean whose
doors were what was i going to be
knocking on so
um it took a minute to get used to the
idea of going there and doing this work
but then it was just really about who is
this community of human beings as an
ecosystem and how does this economy here
how do these how do these corporations
affect what life on the ground is like
and so that really just became my
mo it worked great and and could you
could you so mary beth and i at this
point it's it's um i know you're so far
away we're sitting
we've been there together really closely
for a long time so i i yeah it'll just
be will you say a little bit about where
you come from the work that you've done
before because that's so important to
how you're able to see the valley
well i'd love to see something about
that and then i also want to say a
little bit more about this invitation
from fred
so i my roots are in journalism but i
have in the last 10 years done these
long-term in-depth projects in
communities so first in my hometown of
brockton mass which is right
down the road and i've thought so much
about being um
from brockton and and how growing up as
the granddaughter of immigrants
i feel so connected to immigrants and
newcomers and those layers of those
those layers of social change that
happen with economies shifting and those
that's that's who i feel the most
connected to and that's where my work
really started wasn't trying to say you
know growing up in brockton
which was a rich and beautiful and
incredible experience with the most
amazing people that's not what the
public perception is of a place like
that that's not what you read about in
the globe
and yet the pride and the um the layers
of love that i have for that place are
so are so deep so
um my photography became a way to push
against what wasn't being seen kept
going all the way back to my you know my
kind of earliest memories
fred's invitation was a really
interesting one because it was about
someone who really did understand the
place from a certain level fred so fred
comes in as the perfect collaborator
because what photographers are often
doing is photographing life on the
street but not really understanding what
they're seeing and the meaning of of
what they're seeing so the best was that
fred had this real love for photography
and real appreciation for it but knew
what the value was all about so we had
these we got into this work mode where i
was going out and talking to people and
figure out what life was like and then
bring it back to him and his wife annie
and we would sort of wrestle with the
meaning of what i was seeing and so
together we birthed this
work that we think really gets at that
but i it would have been hard for either
of us to do it alone i think both of us
were also coming professionally from
worlds where there's a tradition that
either a writer drives a project that is
then illustrated by a photographer or a
photographer drives a project and then a
writer writes some stuff around it and
you know one of the things that's nice
about working with you and it's very
different than trying to work with this
other photographer before was that it
was totally collaborative all the way
mary beth taught me something new every
single week
and you were very patient with me as i
um mailed you academic books
yeah i really underlined a lot of books
yeah and that that was really powerful
you know we work really so
your daughter's advice i think was just
do what you always do walk around and
talk to people
how did that fly in silicon valley
walking down the street just being like
excuse me i'm a photographer i would
like to you know how did you make the
connections
you know why it was amazing because um
[Music]
everyone living there is aware of the
myth
and aware of the discrepancy between the
mythology on the other side and what
their life is like so there wasn't a
person who i said go ahead they're aware
and they're concerned
yeah concerned and just um just
conscious
it's like it's like a it's like living
inside disney world except you're not um
yeah except you're you're invisible
you're not mickey out there you're
behind the curtain making it all happen
for mickey and your your
uh
life is just not part of that so i have
another analogy that i want to bring in
right here so so my first intellectual
affection was the early american
puritans um i was really in love with
puritan
of the 1620s back in the day um
somebody's got to do it anyways um
i often used to wonder what would it be
like if i could actually wander around
in plymouth massachusetts in 1620 and
make pictures
and what would that be like and i
realized this has been in our
conversation for a long time the silicon
valley is the city on a hill for our
time it's held up as a kind of sparkling
target for people around the world this
is how we ought to be this is how we
ought to live
but in fact much like the original
plymouth massachusetts it's a place
where some people are depicted and
understand themselves as saints
and other people are depicted and
understand themselves as less than human
and capturing that distinction
was something that i think we really
worked out together
well i don't think they understand
themselves oh fair point yes
sorry but they know that they're not
part of the main story that's right even
though they're working to make it happen
the main story is depending on their
yeah but okay so you said the publisher
said like that's not silicon valley we
have no idea what you're talking about
um
but it was crazy
so i'd like to hear more about that
story and just like shocking the book
and the ups and downs of that
um and the conversations you had and
then i'd also like to know like is there
some sense in which
this uh
sparkling target that is
like that that is tarnishing that people
are now maybe just because they're
saying in congress all the time they're
like realizing there's some kind of
trouble here that we don't quite grasp
on is that miss starting to if not fall
apart but like adjust and change
so it's a two-part question
i hope so i'll start it and then yeah
yeah so so um
i didn't thought the book would be an
easy sell i love photography i have a
large collection of photography books at
the time i had an agent i have a strong
publishing record i wrote my newspapers
and magazines i thought this was
think it not going to be a problem
and so she started taking the project
around we ordered the book it looks
pretty much like it looks now um
you know available with a discount
just saying um but so the book was a
really i thought of a quite a beautiful
project she couldn't sell it and
everywhere she went they would say
sometimes they would say photography
books don't sell that well modern modern
matter but the thing that we heard much
more frequently was that's not silicon
valley silicon valley is
and then it would be you know zuckerberg
um tesla elon musk um young white men
etc and while we're working on the book
actually tell you a little bit about
national geographic and your experience
with them
well and yes and we also it wasn't just
that we were showing it to money people
who did who wanted something saleable i
mean we showed it to a very
internationally prominent sociologist
don't forget
that's right this isn't this isn't
silicon valley yeah
so um the national geographic at the
time was publishing an issue just about
silicon valley and they um
you know i think fred was friends
shaking his head he was more irate about
it
uh they were into the whole
all the stuff all of the tech
development and the startups and the
wacky ideas did you know that engineers
are polyamorous
did you know that they form cuddle
puddles
these and these pictures these pictures
of these young beautiful all-white
beautiful people men and women both
piled up in like white clothes
was just wild and so those were the bulk
of the images back to you
there were some images that were more
working-class people who were trying to
make it work there were some but i you
know i was in journalism for a long time
and i
am friendly with someone who was an
editor there and she wrote to me and
said um
we heard you have pictures of people in
trailers
and
they published one of my pictures
because whoever the photographer was
that they had invited out didn't didn't
get into that level of life and so the
homelessness and the working poor and
these are you know the working homeless
um was something that we were so focused
on that we couldn't imagine that a
national
geographic photographer could spend a
significant amount of time in silicon
valley and not get at that and that's
the power of the myth
this is the 1620 problem in silicon
valley you know you go there and you
immediately see the saints you've been
told to look for and that's very
powerful but you but you do in the
process of doing that you unseat all the
people around you the unseeing was
something that i'd experienced just by
living there and you know going out to
dinner and seeing the way that people
treat people but but you came in with a
different view and the other thing we
really struggled to do and you'll see it
in the book is really capture people at
every level of the social strategy
they're trying to try very hard to do
the algo sander thing at least a little
bit and try to capture everyone so there
are people there who are you know
founders of companies and have fancy
houses with pools and there are folks
like the woman who runs the taco truck
on the cover
it's the valley as it is
we sent it to we sent it to a magazine
in california that said well this is an
interesting view i mean we really got so
much rejection and then what happened
was we got so much rejection and we said
okay
uh fred had a publisher in france
and
the
europeans could really see
what the americans were seeing
is exactly right that something changed
in america
as they see many things in silicon
valley before we do um but they you know
something changed in american tech last
[ __ ] also black lives matter
in a way that suddenly it seemed like oh
yeah gosh there are people of color
that seemed like a thing that editors
could suddenly see
they really couldn't see that earlier it
was really fascinating like no
um and so so those cultural changes made
it possible for others to see it in the
book when the book actually came out
thrilled to see on amazon with all its
wonderful metrics best seller in
photography
no like that was that was so satisfying
right and so that didn't last forever
[Music]
it lasted long enough to give me a
thrill
me too
he was the exorcist in the new york
times yeah that was a good game that was
a thrill also
also take one note on that and give your
times a high five
new york times not known for
taking the point of view of the work um
as a general thing especially in the
business section
and the thing and this really goes back
to the quality of marybeth's images
those image we had 15 images in a
two-page spread
in the business section
targeted at executives on the same day
that elon musk hosted snl yeah that's
right and i say i give i give the times
props for that and so one of the things
i'm proudest of in the project is thanks
to your images we were able to at least
bring
15 images of the working class to the to
the leadings other than the wall street
journal leading business section on the
planet for executives they had to see
them at least for those 10 minutes and
then maybe two or three images of there
was a wealthy uh widow they're not
wealthy by the standards of that area
just wealthy you know
a human you know um
and i think just maybe holding a dog
yeah and then there's that couple that
has two children but they can't afford
to furnish their home their empty rooms
and they you know
they're sitting there
you know and then everyone else is in
the taco truck the person in the trailer
yeah would it be helpful if we showed
some images to folks i would love for
you to show some images and then i had a
question about those images like the
ones that
i looked at um there is
i mean i don't want to use the word
repetitive in a pejorative way but i see
a framing of people looking directly at
the camera yeah in a
uh yeah
just like i am witnessing
this and i'd like to get a sense of why
this is a great question and and
um
we've talked a lot about this but i
think did we read your shirt i heard the
question yeah there was one point i
wanted to throw out before we go to the
pictures though which is
one of the reasons that really one of
the things that really animated us um
socially and politically is that we see
the country moving in the direction of
silicon valley the economy of the
country as a whole
and that communities as a whole are
moving this direction so silicon valley
ends up being the sort of beacon if you
want to go with this mode of capitalism
that we're in this is where we're going
to end up and it ends up not being good
for people is what we are arguing
okay so i'm going to share my screen
okay great thank you andrew and i hope
you'll answer him this question i have
my yeah my eyebrows are a little
different which i think is also
interesting
um and how do i get rid of this little
bar andre just grab it oops grab it
slide it
i don't have away cursor anymore
oops
i think sorry i think i need help the
cursor's gone
just start personally
cursor yeah
where did it go
i can see it
it keeps going right over there
can i exit out yeah sure
well we'll move it first how about that
yep
there we go okay got it
okay thank you
i am screen sharing okay great
okay so is that thing too annoying for
words should i just leave it there it's
great it's fine
um okay so this is theresa this is the
cover of the book uh her daughter texted
me today
theresa was working in a taco truck i'll
tell i'll just tell a little bit about
how i met each person and then please if
anybody has a question jump in or if i'm
talking too long jump in i will
definitely does that
i will also
talk about the aesthetic choices in the
politics of those because they have some
politics well yeah and i you know
yes ma'am why did you choose that photo
uh for the cover oh great question
that's a good question
we
sure i can uh
i can show her the french cover really
easily
we
this was the french cover
and i was actually working with an
editor at the national geographic doing
or teaching a workshop when we were
trying to figure out the
cover for the french book
and it was between these two and he this
is a picture from the apple headquarters
so it was this grand opening of the new
apple headquarters that big spaceship
thing and we were in this gorgeous
marble space where all it's all been
written about the marble and the
aesthetics and there was this woman who
was just going back and forth cleaning
the glass cleaning glass and so this
shadow
of her just felt like what we're trying
to talk about which is the underpinnings
of the valley
the book came out it did well in france
but the designer was a woman named cinda
hitchcock who's at risky and a dear
friend of mine i was like i don't know
about this beige book anymore she she
had done this and she thinks and and
there's the portraits are so
much about this eye contact that we
decided um when we did this book to do
eye contact and this might be kind of
interesting i don't know
um
we were trying to choose between
um
warren
c warren
who is a venture capitalist and had done
very well and had um his business and
his contribution to the narrative of the
story was sort of about
um his feelings about where companies
were going wrong ethically and how to
grow big without
going off the rails
um what other pictures did we think
about friends i think those were the two
big those are the two finalists those
were the two and so this picture was
like this feels like what one might
expect from the valley so they're all
this is these are his employees they
bought this house this is his house on
the left he was able to buy another
property this is a half a block from the
famous garage where um
pepper started in palo alto they're all
barefoot they're on their laptops and we
thought that this actually we needed
this picture because we needed to show
that we weren't avoiding this person
but that we were
we were including this person from a
different angle and a different and a
different perspective did you say those
were his workers these are his employees
because he reads that's like his family
right but that's what these but
he bought this house and so they're all
allowed
that's a defining future of elite work
in silicon valley exactly precisely the
ability to connect your family so i
spent a lot of time inside facebook and
not met up with facebook and they say
bring your whole self to work you know
and they celebrate on the walls their
posters for you know celebrate lgbtq and
trends and oh you know they have posters
of the lord
organizer on their wall even though they
would never permit a union in the shop
and so i would say that the creation of
the faux community is a management
strategy across the valley you see it in
play here
so this is where he lives and then they
bought this house but i mean he's a
really lovely guy he's a great you know
he's a great guy but he's able to create
this work environment okay so teresa
um
i met her after a long day of shooting i
stopped um in
i stopped in palo alto there was a food
truck and there was music and i stopped
to like eat dinner and relax
and when i this is the sort of the art
part of it is um
where my gut gets engaged and where my
eye gets engaged and where i just have
this instinct to go oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god i gotta go back to
the camera camera bag and you know like
something so amazing
so she turns and asks her boss so the
boss is okay so now i'm climbing up into
the food truck and in the back so this
is in the back of the food truck super
tight and i only had three frames but
she had to get back to work you know so
i took three frames
and i mean i know why i love this
picture is that her she is so
um present and direct and
aware and with me and
um
you know her her presence is so solid
and i you know aesthetically i love the
gloves i love
this and her neck i love the way that
she's framed in the black doorway and
then all the other stuff is all around
her and we just really felt like this is
the person who people aren't seeing when
they're talking about that
it could have been a lot of people
but there was something so she's not
confrontational but she's definitely
like saying
to me she's saying are you do you see me
or not you know am i part of the record
or not i want to build on this because
we thought about it a lot and you know
the a couple of different pieces we were
by the time the french book had gone
through a process
we were still wrestling with this deep
you know what silicon valley are you
depicting and what part of the decision
between those two was do we try to make
the book do we try to get past that by
saying yes you see it's still silicon
valley or do we confront it by saying no
this is actually the silicon valley mary
beth pushed very hard for this image i
think that was the right call i mean
it's right called a variety of ways
first off the class range in silicon
valley is very different than anybody
talks about there's a much wider range
the second ethnicity i mean this is this
is a woman of color in a world that is
in which all of the saints are depicted
as white men
and so that's really important this is a
woman who does labor with her hands
which is again something that is not
emphasized in the valley and all of that
is super visible in the image the other
piece has been very important to me and
gets to the aesthetic of mary beth's
work is that she's not just treated with
a kind of respect and i will say that
this is one of the very rare portraits
in the book where you did not get to
know the person for a long time before
you were shot right so you actually went
in and shot right off the bat
right um one of the things that i love
about the picture is that that idiom
that that could have been painted you
know in the 16th century in italy
the way that her body is held you know
that's a dif that's a posture and a
portraiture and a look and a respect for
the image that echoes down through art
history to a very traditional but also
very powerful place
and so the invocation of that place
however suddenly especially in this
context seemed important
what do you think what do you think i
really like i mean like my research is
about the library workers in new york
city
and i also took photographs so i
struggled you know like just choosing my
photos so i was just wondering because
[Music]
should we look at some more pictures
what should we do should we look at a
few more so this is christopher to
answer your question about the direct
gaze you know i worked for
decades um feeling like a documentary
photographer
in which my role was to organize myself
around the action so that i could so
that i could catch a moment that felt
like an authentic moment of what was
happening
and then i became interested in
portraiture in
2015 i started working on direct
portraiture and just really enjoying
this
this relationship and this moment of the
direct gaze and and then had one when
you stop someone on the street the
artistic challenge when you stop someone
on the street and say can i make a
portrait of you and they say yes then
you're both kind of like well what do we
do now you know and so how to solve that
problem how to solve it through the
narrative how to solve it through the
relationship how to solve it through the
aesthetics of what's happening in that
in that moment in that moment in time so
i just kind of got in i hadn't really
explored that direct thing before and it
felt like the right way for these people
to be speaking
visually for our for our book so this is
crystal ball so kristen ball is a um
a security we'll just show you a few
pictures he's a security guard at
facebook
um and i met him because when they were
the workers in space were trying to form
a reunion
i i met him through some social uh
through some organizing label organizing
people
and
when i met him we met at a restaurant we
had this huge long interview and when he
brought me back to his house i realized
we've been at the front of the house in
menlo park and then he brought me around
to the back and i realized that he was
living in this [ __ ]
so you know in this idea of you know and
and he's a full time
so that to me was really important to
find someone who was working at one of
the big companies but couldn't afford to
live i just want to emphasize that's
that's in every way a representative
relationship not an unusual person you
know what mary beth founded the security
guard would be true of the kitchen staff
the preschool teachers
on down the line
well how does the econ i mean
how far can these cobble together sort
of solutions go because if people um
to have this lifestyle
um
they and they want to say have children
they need someone to teach their
children
exactly no one is going to drive eight
or nine hours you know a day to teach
their children they can do better
so so how does it become sustainable not
to mention just like they need someone
to take the garbage out they need
someone to pick it up from the curve you
know let me let me let me let me ask
that question but
by breaking apart the word sustainable
into two categories persistent and
sustainable
um the first question i think is how and
why has this persisted for so long right
people do drive several hours each way
um and you know the the and i think the
answer to wise is twofold at least one
is the economic differential is so
extreme
so across the mountains from from palo
alto is the second poorest county in
america
the only one that supported one in
mississippi that's poor
you put that kind of poverty within
driving distance of a place where in
2018 there were 74 billionaires in a
two-county region you're gonna have
people driving across the mountains okay
so just that difference is so enormous
and in terms of keeping that persistent
i think you keep the difference up it's
perverse in fact as long as you keep
some people extraordinarily rich and
other people extraordinarily poor it's
like it's like creating a sucking vacuum
those people need whatever money they
can get and there's always someone
behind them there was someone behind
them exactly so that's system
self-perpetuating the other piece of
that that's really important is ideology
as long as we keep as journalists and
reporters and media people telling
stories about heroic creative
disembodied mostly young mostly white
mostly male workers having genius ideas
sprouting from their minds you know
shooting off from the ground and you
know rockets you know as long as we're
doing that
then we're not going to break down what
we're trying to do here say no we need
to build media and do business for
society as a whole not just for
for leaders okay that's important how do
we make sustainable
that question i think is is a very even
important one and i think that the first
thing that we need to do is actually
accept that
business and technology are not there to
make a profit
profit is there to make a society to
make it better this is actually
something that was widely understood in
mid-century american business we don't
tend to think of this now in my archival
life i spent a long time reading the
first two years of the ford foundation
reports which are places where corporate
leaders in 1951-52 get together and try
to figure out how to
do corporate work for america and the
ethos then is one of believe it or not
we at chrysler really need to do what's
good for the country that's our job as
businessmen we need to do that we need
to not let salaries get out of hand
there's a settlement with unions there's
a sense that we are all in this together
and now it's a post world war ii moment
we need to reconstruct the notion that
we are all in this together how we do
that is a long and complicated and hard
story part of it i think involves
government regulation part of that i
think involves telling different kinds
of stories our tiny piece of it is
trying to say here's the we that's in it
because that weed is not in the story
please just i'm just gonna say though
that i think the definition of what's
good for the country
is still
a racist and misogynistic very very
very good
this is also a time without question
yeah without without question no i think
that's i i think that's an incredibly
important point i see it as a more mixed
time than we remember um
i wouldn't deny segregation for a second
but i would also know even in the places
of the greatest depression in the
american army
there are efforts to desegregate and to
integrate and begin to build a different
america even in the places where the
oppression is taking place i try to hold
on to that
but we can go longer on this yeah
margin and what kind of profit margin
needed to be maintained the reason that
we're talking about too that that's
really
gone off the deep end now with uh
i think fred i do think so um
yeah i read it i read it a little bit
differently i also really want to just
say that i heard in the comments
i really didn't hear that
i don't know what to do
it is thinking
to hear that um yeah i think the private
margins have become grotesque
um actually we've kind of kind of
actually read this to read this cultural
language well they've gotten trapped in
a strange kind of mythological spiral
right so one of the deepest stories in
america it comes from that founding
moment when the british come and they
say look
god has decided who's going to heaven
it's predestination god's decided he's
going to heaven now we can't know who
that is but chances are that if god
loves you enough to send you to heaven
he's going to get you rich here on earth
and so gradually wealth in 17th century
america becomes an emblem of potential
salvation that idea permeates american
society it permeates it across the race
lines i mean considering
i don't know how deep we go into
that kind of theology but you know it's
it's it's across america it's very
powerful silicon valley stands as an
emblem of that idea that in fact god has
decided that some people are saved and
others are not as long as you buy into
that as long as you buy into the idea
that wealth is some form of salvation
the spiritual and the commercial are
aligned in that deep way it's very hard
to make cases for other things other
ways of being
that's truly true in the post-world war
ii era as the institute institutions of
sociability begin to
um come are declining other spaces are
declining and it gets much harder to
build the kind of society
kind of do things together across
different lines
um that we desperately need and so that
theology commercial theology is
everywhere
that would be my riff on it but i don't
know
i don't know other folks too i wonder if
we could see some more sure look at a
few more pictures okay because all right
yeah let me run through okay so here's
imelda who um i you know when i was
there the first time i i was there for
six weeks in 2017 i rented an airbnb
and i saw this woman coming out of a
house two women with mops and and
buckets and i went and spoke to them
again in spanish
and i just said you know i'm married
with me i'm a photographer i'm working
on a project about life in silicon
valley you want to tell me and
mel said yes and she wrote down her
number and i called her and
um we
met she and again she said meet me at
this gas station she was in redwood city
meet me at this gas station and i met
her at the gas station and she got my
car and she took me down this little
street and again we didn't go into the
house we went into the trailer in the
driveway where there were no there was
no running water and we ended up going
into the house where there were three
generations of a family living but i
mean so this became so common that i
wasn't looking for desperation it became
so common that every time i entered a
space looking for a working person that
this was the living situation so we we
spent a lot of time together when i was
there
and um
uh we made this portrait in her
trailer this is ravi and gutami so we
wanted to talk about um the different
different you know engineers coming from
all over the world to silicon valley who
don't you know who maybe are not part of
the dominant narrative and you know they
belong to this community of immigrants
from india that's been growing there
since the 1980s
uh and one and and you know and they
talked about they want to have a family
they're both pharmaceutical engineers
they went to from um india to the united
states they met many stops before they
got to silicon valley when they got
there they thought we're not going to be
able to raise a family here in this you
know apartment for three thousand
dollars a month
pause for a fact yeah 40 of the citizens
of silicon valley were born in another
country
and um fewer than 50 percent speak
english as their first language in the
home which is just a sort of interesting
thing it sort of it is sort of an island
and an interesting way and you have a
sense of the
percentage of undocumented people
because when i asked the question about
sustainability that's why i mean for
staying sustainable for whom yeah
but but
does the system function in function
however it does yeah in part because
there are undocumented people that
if the situation becomes unaccountable
for them they will either keep going
or they will even be replaced by more
undocumented people is that a key part
of the dynamics
i do not have stats on undocumented
people because that's on poverty and
poverty is robust i mean 14
women pregnant women do not have um what
would constitute sufficient food um 14
think about the pregnant woman not
having enough food um
i can go on down the line with this it's
not helpful i do think that
your point of very best point about
persistent the persistent availability
of impoverished workers is right on
point
so i was trying i did i did start to
make these kinds of
fred started calling them the
interstitial pitch pictures
why use one syllable
right now i started to just sort of
grasp at these scenes that were kind of
that i was seeing every day as i was
driving down the highway and there was
this funny
kind of judeo-christian pushback
from the community against what
the new
kind of sacred temples had become and i
just
oh no you're still
i'm still it makes it look like they're
not on the zoo
the screen is it's a difference
but mine this is the difference
now you're back
[Music]
because you were basically telling the
big variant story
but he tells the story really
differently he tells the indian really
differently right like
the actual meaning
for the quest the salvation falls out
that's the iron cage so i was interested
in your twist on it like right
sides yeah so so i think that the the
yeah for vapor the the the meaning of
the search the religious that
specifically
we're just doing just doing that and i
think that's fair i think that's totally
fair in this case i do think that
silicon valley is a much more religious
place than anyone thinks
it's really actually interesting it's
settled by catholics actually um yeah
and it's still quite catholic um it's
but it's it's actually religiously quite
diverse i live on a street that's um
near a very main dragon the main drag
was designed when the area was built to
have a line of churches and they're
pretty full
um which is also clear there's also a
very strong very conservative
evangelical
evangelical style right
so so i do think that's i do think
that's there but you're absolutely right
i i think that um
the fantasy of glittering heavenly
wealth
permeates the valley and you almost
can't separate the glitter and the the
heavenliness
from its religious roots if you know the
religious roots you don't know that it's
just like getting rich yeah and the
potential yeah go for it
you can always make it you're gonna make
it yeah right
fail fast fail often
it only works
all right okay all right so this you
know these things that keep that keep
showing up this is the facebook bus so
there are these unmarked
blackout windowed buses that the
companies send around to get their
employees so the employees so we started
talking a lot fred and i started talking
a lot about community health and what
does community health need so when not
only are you buying into if you're if
you're wealthy can you buy into this buy
yourself a bubble but the employees are
floating in these worlds that are not
interacting so if you're a facebook
employee you're not standing at the bus
stop with everybody else on market
street in san francisco the bus is
coming for you and you can get your hair
cut and you can get your teeth clean all
kinds of things happen on the campuses
the bus is coming to a public bus stop
yeah because the company has made an
arrangement with the state so that
special special buses can stop there and
what is essentially a public resource
and this pattern of
taking private advantage of public
resources permeates the valley and much
of american life
so you know chad um fred talks a lot
about
my upbringing in brockton math but i
mean it's it's
my feeling in my bones is we are
enriched by being in close proximity
with one another all the time whether
it's
in the market in schools at the bus stop
and what these companies are doing is
taking the valley and really stratifying
it and so people are not interacting so
they don't even are they're not even
seeing the people who are working to
support the companies that they're
working for
so this is richard one of my all-time
favorite people
um i had learned through
uh some research that the afl-cio was
trying to organize at tesla
and that the meetings were happening at
a site
and was able to
you know be present and i was introduced
by the person who was doing a
presentation which is about workplace
safety and trying to tell tesla workers
you know you've got rights um and and
how to identify abuses and how to speak
up and so i'm sitting at the table and
i'm like oh my god look at richard you
know i just like have that that's when
my heart and everything is just like oh
god i hope he lets me photograph him you
know
and i talked to him recently and he said
remember how you were way hoping that i
would let you know
that i was saying that i said guys
you love that story so i sat through
this whole meeting on please not this
guy yesterday
tesla took over
and he had lived his life as an american
auto worker and he was making six
figures when that plant shut down
um and then tesla comes in and he ends
up on the floor making something like
this
yeah 18 an hour 40 something 40 000 a
year
and his and and he ended up being he's
in the news you can look him up because
he ended up being he started organizing
he started working with the af afl-cio
and started to
talk to workers about their rights and
he was saying you know i saw guys
sleeping in their vans working 18-hour
shifts blowing out their shoulders
sleeping in the van taking a shower in
the locker room and come back and do it
again he's starting to organize he gets
fired
so elon musk was found in contempt i
mean
it was found to be an illegal firing
that um that violated the law about
organizing being legal
and elon
appealed at something like three times
he was ordered to pay him back paying
reinstate his job and as of now richard
is still not working what he said to me
on the phone was
my back pay is like a penny to tesla
he's not getting he keeps appealing to
send the message in richard's view not
to organize to to should i build this
yeah i think the image reveals an
economic pattern that is permeating
america right now and i think this is
part of the work right
companies like tesla and others and that
run those buses are trying to kind of
build um an economic world in which
post-quote thinking workers live above
and cut off from anyone who works with
their bodies
and in the universities this is told to
us as the triumph of post-industrialism
the triumph of network society the
triumph of the space flows in the manual
castel's idiom and um in point of fact
what happens is that while they're
constructing this illusion of kind of
the cloud floating safely and naturally
above the world they're pushing down
super hard on workers
and in a very embodied very driven very
directed way that takes full advantage
of poverty racial difference all of the
social social schisms that actually are
american
and it's it's it's really really nasty
it's surfacing that surfacing the bodies
of people seem really important to us we
talked a lot about that we talked a lot
about getting bodies back in the mix
because they're not in the conversation
well i mean and that's all that's all i
have
you know what if you know what i mean
when that's what that's all i have is
the conversations and the interactions
with the actual people you know i'm not
doing the research
um so since that's all i bring
in the bodies you know it wasn't like i
had a choice
right right
um abraham and brenda live in a trailer
outside stanford's campus
um and this is someone who had a
drywalling business that he lost in 2008
and was in the crash and then was trying
to keep things going and they were
living in people's sheds and then the
authorities would come and
the shed would get torn down they'd go
to another friend's house they'd go to
another friend's house so they took
their savings and they bought this
trailer and they lit and so when you go
to stanford
you know that palm drive that incredible
well perpendicular to that palm drive
and all of the beautiful landscape these
entire world trailers
which most of which house working people
i
learned that there was a woman who
worked in the stanford bookstore who
lived in one of those but i was never
able to find her that was something but
i did meet abraham or brenda and what
happens with stanford is that when
there's an important football game like
the homecoming game they order all the
trailers to clear out
and so abraham and brenda you know go
over to half moon bay or do something
beautiful uh
with the day but can you imagine so this
image control
right front yeah i mean it's almost so
amazing that i i'm thinking is this real
even as i'm saying it to you now but
they tolerate it
because they have to for the system to
function
except when there's an image crisis
well
we know that they do i don't know if i
can say that for sure but i know that on
a day of an important game they are
they have been ordered to leave i don't
know how they do that though
so there's actually a real issue about
this right now i live in mountain view
and in mountain view the city has
outlawed trailers on all city sponsored
boats all city roads are now they spend
a million dollars putting up signs
saying you know no trip no parking of
vehicles longer than x dimension here
this is victor this is mountain view
completely shapely this mountain victor
lives in one of these trailers here so
those are all gone now by rachel park
not done yet
okay that's fine
[Music]
um so the except that there are two
exceptions to this rule in mountain view
and in palo alto
and that is the first phone roads you
can still park a trailer
and that is a state-owned road and
that's where all of these ones outside
stanford are parked they're all on el
camino real the other exception is by
city there are still a couple designated
spots where people are fighting to stay
and this road near rankstore park is one
of them and one of the reasons they're
allowed to stay there is because it's
the mexican neighborhood right so now
you'll be thrilled to know that mountain
view is now now
creating a discrete advertising campaign
mountain view exclusive community in an
inclusive community
an inclusive community um and it says
absolutely nothing about class focuses
exclusively on ethnic diversity which
allows them to focus exclusively on
international tech workers
that's actually fascinating it's
completely fascinating so this remains
kind of invisibleized
and this is very much under threat i
mean these big these will go away as
soon as the lawsuits work their way
through the
system
the last thing i kind of want to bring
up is this the
fred does a lot of work on invisibility
of um pollution
and how toxic um what are the numbers so
pause for a second silicon valley is
actually
the most polluted region in america
though we don't talk about this um the
santa clara county one of the two
counties that make up the valley has the
single highest density of superfund
sites in america it's worth the love
canal
superfund sites are sites left behind
polluted sites left behind by
corporations where the corporation goes
bankrupt or is otherwise unable to clean
it up and the responsibility falls to
the government those sites are ranked in
the order of desperate need for repair
superfund sites are the most desperately
in need of repairs this is like love
canal
one of the first things you do when you
buy a house in silicon valley is you get
a superfund site map
online to make sure that you aren't near
a pollution plume
um and you really try to figure that out
we have houses in mountain view you're
going to marry about we'll talk about
this in a second that are built five
feet off the ground
and their advertisements have been here
you can have one right there yeah this
is sunnyvale but same thing
yeah so these houses are advertised in
the mountain view cases having
above-ground basements this is a benefit
to you you don't have to go below the
ground to store your stuff
why well they're built on top of things
called tce plumes tce is industrial
solvent that flows through the ground
and it off gases and it's toxic um in a
certain density as it rises up
and apparently the toxicity falls below
the government mandated toxicity level
for humans to live with it three feet
off the ground
so your basement is five feet
and this is but this is a really
expensive neighborhood yeah that's true
i mean the house is a little teeny
bungalow is a million two million
dollars this is what it looks like with
the
remediation
you know you know and this is mark whose
mother worked in
technology in the 70s and 80s before the
regulations place now
were were there and she was working
fusing you know when you go to the
grocery store and
you beat the laser she was fusing the
glass to create that laser and she was
working with lead she was working with
molten lead and she had a miscarriage
and then she had had mark who had severe
disabilities and then she was driving
around the valley and heard an ad
for a law office on the car radio that
said were you working in technology
during these years of a baby that meets
these um that meets this description she
was able to
take it through the courts but this is
not um uncommon for kids to be born with
birth defects
yes should we do this
yeah one of them should open up to q a
and should i stop screen sharing
i'll leave it i don't know just the
option of like going back to images
would be great
um i'm happy either way but we'd
definitely like to answer questions yeah
yeah whatever's on book spots
i've been asking questions but i'm just
going to start with one that might be
dropped which is uh
your
one of your your key terms for thinking
this through is mythology thinking about
myths of perfect places um but as i was
looking through the book of reading
utopia
and i started getting started falling
right into margaret atwood which is what
happens to me often um and thinking
about the kinds of systems that she
and that's her
the way that she conceptualized
she has a word use topia which fuses
utopian dystopia it's not the most
elegant word but her point is that any
utopia is a dystopia
because there's always someone who
thinks that the system is
amazing
it works it works really well for
someone and it's not the perfect world
and handmade handmade sales from
dystopia to most readers but there are
characters
you know capital punishment kicks in
when when people have an abortion or
perform an abortion this is a perfect
world yeah which of course we're seeing
you know right something we're thinking
about in our imperfect world so i'm just
wondering to voice
the concept of utopia we're used to
being failed utopia uh comes into play
and also in her world it's very in her
fictional world
there's intentionality people are
building structures right that make
everything better for them that they
know makes it worse for others but
that's okay because they're better is
the best the most important better right
um and so there's an intentionality and
say where do we let the trailers fart
you know what's the zoning issue here
how do we you know
you know how do we make sure
i wouldn't have believed the
intentionality
argument until my wife and i went to a
city council meeting about the trailers
it started at 6 p.m
and there were all these
all these working-class families there
many mexican-americans some of them
didn't speak english all of them had
kids tons of kids families all there to
protest the imminent pushing away of the
trailers
and the meeting went on and celebrated
the softball team
and the high school and the new lawn on
the track field the time goes on the
parents started leaving the kids to bed
finally 11 30 p.m we take up the issue
of trailers and almost all the families
are gone
and it was just incredibly clear at that
moment to me
that actually our city council worked
very clearly for the tech firms and
developers i had not fully grocked that
now i will confess right so
i um this is my period of confession
i
one of the reasons i wanted to do this
work one of the things i focus so much
on mythology and my academic work
is you know i i'm disappointed i fell in
love
as a 23 year old
with the fantasy of
a community of saints living in a brand
new land that puritans offer i fell in
love with that fantasy i think it's a
fantasy that animates
of early america
for
you know rich white men
um and i was in that category for sure
of people who for whom this was built to
work
and i was excruciatingly pained by the
fact that it wasn't working not only for
people who didn't look like me but for
everybody including
and i think the thing that we inhabit
now the thing that gets me going in
silicon valley is that this place
is being offered as a utopia in the
stories that we tell about what america
ought to become
but it is precisely a dystopia in the
deepest possible way and it works
forever narrower slices of people and
there are absolutely people when you're
talking about how like they're people
say this is the perfect world for me and
i'm building it better for me i know
those people absolutely and for those
people these are not fully people
on the screen right and
and so
as a sort of disappointed former member
of that world
i want to figure out how to make the
world
better in a different way that's i guess
my motivation pains me to know that but
i think that's where i'm at
can i ask a question
yeah sure
i guess i wonder like do you need pain
in order to empathize and stuff so
because to me that's what strikes me as
the problem like you know we're
expecting empathy through
like even the most richest of
billionaires stuck in the bubble should
be able to see people as people without
feeling the pain
yeah that's great just because it's
ethically right
you know i was like i don't need to feel
like sometimes in fact i shouldn't have
to pretend empathy right sure which is
the problem with the
so so i foreign lots of thoughts on this
um
my first book was right my first book
was a book about traumatized combat
events um who were able to do what they
did in combat in vietnam
because they had been trained not to see
the enemies human beings
i think there are systems and incentives
that reward folks for not seeing other
folks it's very hard to break through
that
um so i'll give you an example from
facebook facebook surrounds its workers
on the main floor with um with pictures
of people of color of all kinds people
of all diverse orientations everything
works well to others
and you might think if you're a facebook
worker that you are acting as you do
your facebook work acting empathetically
with these this array of um imagined
others
but in point of fact you are mining
their world
so that it can be mapped and monetized
you know as well as captain's review
and so
but how are you going to remember these
regular folks from that space i don't
know all your incentives
what did you call it what capitalist
regime surveillance
well that's the deal i mean doesn't that
seem i always say fred well shouldn't
the billionaires just give up some of
the money and
invest it back in the community like it
doesn't seem that hard
all the money is being siphoned off
sequestered off at the top
and then somebody like jeff bezos gets
props for sending money to wherever he
sends it but i mean
so we're ending here on constance who's
a teacher facebook and she was driving
three hours in and i'm sorry
she's a teacher in menlo park in mello
park at a private school
and she was driving three hours into
town to work and or two hours in and two
hours back and she had these little
girls and they'd get home and they'd be
starving and she wouldn't be able to
cook for them she wasn't able to take a
class so facebook builds teacher housing
and i think they dedicated something
like a billion dollars to this pilot
program for teacher housing which is
right near the campus now there are
other issues because there are people in
the neighborhood who feel that facebook
is really pushed out it's in a
predominantly black community
and so you know uh the picture of
geraldine and the church you know you
know so so there are other issues that
way but they build this housing and
constance is able now to live there she
can afford it the rent is set at a
percentage of her salary
she takes her 10 minutes to get to work
in 10 minutes back she can
she can quantify
the ways in which her life
having has improved because of the time
spent with her kids and and being able
to take a class so it seems like
more of this could work if the companies
took that money and invested it back in
the communities and felt what fred you
were talking about about the forefront
you know this like this this note and
exactly as you're saying just ethically
speaking should a corporation that
relies on the bodies of that that
inhabit this community be responsible to
the community health overall and why or
are we just going to the bottom line and
i want to tie together
very
very much of one mind on this i want to
tie together your question with with
heather's comment
um
one of the things that people do to
build utopias for themselves that
exclude others is they they create
visual regimes they create ways of
literally seeing one another and they
structure those modes of seeing i've
written about this in other contexts
mostly post-combat context about how the
veterans i studied were literally taught
to see vietnamese people in a very
particular way that allowed them to
assault them and very deliberate very
explicit very much part of training
period and one of the things that i
think we've
collectively our generation has seen is
a marketing push from silicon valley led
primarily by apple but other firms as
well to structure how we see our devices
how we see the tech world how we do and
do not see the workers that go into it
by way of example um when i was brought
my first apple mac by the stanford
people who appeared more the stanford
i.t guys takes my hand which is not
something that generally do in this
world it takes
is the product of a regime of the
structuring of our sensations
such that he i know you get a little
willies right yeah right yeah this is a
true story
we do not see
all of the people who build that all the
people who take it down the villages in
which these things are burned to
separate the elements that they can be
sold in china
pollution
none of that what we see is the visual
construction of sleekness smoothness
that's what we're trying to capture in
that first cover
you know so we don't see the shadows
shattered right shadows on this very
slick world it was too subtle we needed
something and said no no a very dear
friend of mine
oh i'm sorry
well i just want to say a dear friend of
mine who's a young photographer uh in
atlanta she's from montgomery alabama a
young black woman
is being approached by
i won't say which corporation right now
to come and do advertising work for them
because she's got this young black
millennial
vibe going in her pictures and that's
what she cares about she photographs the
cells she photographs our community and
they're trying to mine
that aesthetic for their ad campaigns
and i want her because she i want her to
have that income but i'm like oh
[Music]
factory work in the sense like for
example i see that
you know it's one strategy to bring the
teachers near the schools and once when
i need to increase the
salary of factory workers right
um
so i think that actually all workers are
seen as bodybuildable
valley actually i think it's generally
depicted as a question of time
we're coming for you it's just a matter
of time
um and so i i really do think that and i
i i've been a i've been a
jurist for
large grants for ai projects some of
which are about learning and
some of the ones that scare me the most
are
projects that are about using ai to
model and argue
in the
view of presenters
improve the lives of important autistic
children
um deeply disturbing stuff so i think
that's i think everybody's development
i think that um
what goes on in the valley is this this
story about some people are so special
that we have to pay them a lot and some
people are so ordinary that we
and the specialness is constructed to a
series for example to join google right
your specialness is through taking a
very serious series of tests to find out
whether you're a googler
right you do the tests the tests
definitely solicit certain kinds of
practices whether it's our kinds of
knowledge fair enough but they also
demand certain kinds of performance my
favorite example of that scheme is with
startups venture capitalists
routinely seek out and talk about this
they don't seek out ideas so that's a
good starting point they seek out people
they want people who are going to be the
kind of people who will persevere and
help their companies pivot as products
fit what's date so the cup the idea is
pivot but the people stay now what do
those people look like
where have they gone to school
when i first talked to friends of google
about 10 years ago i said well where do
you get oh we have five schools mit
carnegie mellon stanford i mean harvard
princeton was on that list
okay that's a pre-selection so what
we've got to do to get to the place
where we can cut salaries
we've got to imagine that all these
species of work are in essence about
helping people have better lives it's
all work
and it's no special order to write ai
code
than it is to make a beautiful lunch to
teach a beautiful class
and the only way you get away with
paying a teacher 50 000 and a coder half
a million
is by
pretending
that her work is less complex less
important
um and less valuable and that's that's
an ideological project as a visual
component that we're trying to challenge
so i guess my question is
that notion of
attracting top talent is not unique just
to capitalist silicon valley isn't it
it's also the american dream in the
sense of like you want the ideal
immigrant
the immigrant who's an international
student who goes to mit but not the
worker
in you know and you can see it through
harvard and mit cursing through
um so i guess i'm trying to see if there
are other institutions you can link this
to that are outside of connecticut
institute technology
there's a whole series of firms from
different countries that are doing this
it is kind of a global thing but the
piece i want to distinguish
is the distinction between the search
for particular skills search for
particular kinds of people so canada has
a very rigorous application process i've
been exploring it i know um for you know
trump plans
you go north i've discovered that in
fact they'll take older professors if
they're religious
yeah
if they're willing to teach
[Music]
so they have a point system and it's all
about skills and they're very thoughtful
about how they do that i would say that
in our country we're very sloppy about
how we do any of that because we're
looking for a certain kind of person
not just pedigree but also this kind of
entrepreneurial person who fits within
the unspoken foundational mythology
of the nation that you know this is the
kind of person who's going to innovate
bring us new things they are special
they are pre-selected and their
pre-selection their pre-ordination
destination
and they're already that kind of person
in their home country we need them here
because this is the place to be destined
to come
so i think there's a kind of really
robust mythology in play there it's not
about skills we have a lot of difficulty
having conversations about different
skills different kinds of workers we
bought in the country because we're so
boxed in
by this unspoken mythology let me say
one thing about unspoken i'm doing a lot
of work right now in the 70s and 80s and
on religious approaches to media
technology in that period
we here at mit may not think this was
the capitalism is very much alive in the
united states you know in in the late in
the early 80s one survey showed that 33
of americans believed in the rapture
take that into the rapture god is going
to come down
pick us up those who've been selected
and take them to heaven and leave the
rest behind
one three out of 10 americans believe
this
so so again we may imagine that we're
working in a world of ethical
rationality and certainly those of us
who teach it are whatever say rational
choice it's how people work
no it's not
and we live in a world suffused with
religions to fuse with mythology far
more than we know or address and we need
to i'm done now thank you
yes
i just want to say that
you know that that disparate valuation
and actually i guess one
um
clear measure of it is there isn't even
anybody from
the humanities or arts on the search
committee for the new president
oh that is uh
so i will just say briefly that we have
many of the same challenges at stanford
and that some of us inside the
organization are fighting like crazy to
make changes and we'll see what happens
i have a question for mary beth
this is actually ripping off something
that
sent me an email
um
saying that
you know that one question
to raise about this project is you know
why we need to see the value of their
eyes but implicitly to question about
the power of still photography to make
things visible
and the power that images
databases
makes it hard to focus on and i'm
wondering if you could talk a bit about
the power of still now you might say
well
photography is the best because i'm a
photographer and that's what you know
right but as opposed to making films
about uh this kind of material or as
against
databases or um what makes photography
a smart tool to use for thinking through
and exposing
um
injustice and inequality
well i mean i'm not so sure it is always
a smart tool and i think that
photographers have hid behind a notion
of i'm going to make the better
the world a better place by exposing
this injustice
since the beginning of photography but
really photography can often make things
worse by reinforcing the photographer's
own subjectivities certain stereotypes i
mean photography has been a real agent
of
denigration since its inception
of communities of people of color i mean
i'm going to photograph this in a
certain way and then this work sort of
justifies my own subjugation of the
world so i mean that's out there and
that in this moment especially in the
hands of a white photographer i think um
is really important to to be aware of
and to and to push against i mean fred
and i
had wonderful disagreements
big fights
about about all this but i mean so
so i mean photography is my
the medium that i love because i love
the encounter i love this moment of
making something aesthetic i love there
being this object that
stays still that can be returned to over
time
um and again the the installation work
that i do is about these huge images
being in a space that people do pass by
over time and have noted to me that the
image stays the same but they change in
relation to the image as they're
thinking it through and imagining what
are my own preconceptions about this
person and when i learned that person
how does that shift and how do i come to
um become fond of this image and not
wanted to leave the cityscape
i think i think a lot about um
uh but but you know the fact that i love
to make photography is enough of
justification because of the damage that
i think photography has done in the
world and so
one scholar that i think a lot about is
sarah elizabeth lewis who teaches at
harvard who edited the vision and
justice issue of aperture in 2017 and
um
you know it's just a rock star at
convening thinkers and artists and
writers around these issues and
she really believes in the power of the
aesthetic encounter to move a person um
beyond the limits of what they're seeing
now
and so if you stand in front of a work
of art you know i don't know if you've
ever had the experience of standing in
front of mark rothko and bursting into
tears i have you know that there's
something about standing in front of an
image or experiencing something that's
beautiful formally that can open you up
in a way that's not exactly intellectual
and it's not exactly literal
but that's that's something
so um
i'm not claiming that these pictures are
roth go esque but that i try to get
a viewer to a place that's elevated from
the daily because in the day we're
passing each other and we're passing
each other and the light is bad
and the pole is sticking out of your
head and the
bars and i'm hungry and i can't and i'm
stuck on what you know
and and so there's something about
isolating this idea of a human being
and and presenting that in the most
beautiful container i can create to try
to um to try to inspire a contemplative
into which people who don't have the
time and the resources that i do to dig
up the past can look and see the places
that they come from that's really what
i'm trying to do with my work i get it
wrong all the time ray beth and i are a
little different about this i was a
journalist for a long time here in
boston 10 years and
you know i know that i get it wrong
every time i get that that's like given
but i'm trying i try a little more every
time and i'm okay with that i'm okay
with the fact that i will not see the
whole thing i will see it from my
perspective my perspective is sort of
conditioned i just accept that i reserve
the right to look at people who are
different than me and tell stories about
them but try to listen respectfully
while i do that and i deserve the right
to be told i'm wrong you know that's
that's all good um i'll say another
thing just which is which is something
that's a little peculiar about
indigenous i love whether
first good photographs what bruno latour
calls immutable mobiles
they are they know
i've quoted that a million times in the
great work yeah yeah so they're not
there they're mobile things that don't
change
they reward looking at again and again
and again so that's one power another
power though this is where mary beth and
i perhaps differ i think photographs
have a power to be both and
i think photographs taken for awful
purposes
can often reveal things that we don't
expect
and vice versa for
persons of photos taken for
oscillating benevolent reasons can can
hurt people enormously
my favorite work in this regard is by
joshua gamson he's a scholar of gay men
and media
and he showed um very
persuasively the gay men were often
brought on television talk shows in the
early 70s to be made fun of especially
in feminine then that when they were
brought onto shows to be made fun of
audiences reacted very differently saw
them in fact as human beings and these
make fun of settings were actually
gateways to public participation
um for gay men and experienced pre-aids
and i thought that's a very powerful
argument and it's a very interesting
experiment and he makes it pretty
persuasively over two books so i i think
that we live in a world where our
challenge is to see both hands
the thing about the i mean i love film
you know i wouldn't i you know
um those 7up films and all of that
incredible work i mean i like to think
that this is a tiny
contribution but right now we we're
going to talk about this in the next 24
hours but i'm in conversation with
stanford um archives and library about
acquiring this work to
be there for students 100 years from now
to be able to say
what was it like for a worker in the age
of zuckerberg
and so that really
pleases me that long after i'm gone
there's a document that is
in the form of a still image and and
these narratives that will that will
exist have they talked about banners
with you yet
not yet
they want to acquire
photos as objects
that's what we need to talk about
whether it's objects or as digital
right because that's a whole nother
internal conversation also about whether
we can hang banners of these images in
the library for our students to do their
work online because currently they have
a display about silicon valley that's a
as you might imagine a celebration of
heroic inventors that a fair child
semiconductors
and so we're
the only person of color in the entire
display right now is the cover of our
book that's the only thing right now
i haven't looked in the book so this may
be it's coming around yeah
[Music]
but so this may have been absolutely the
scope of the remit of what you're
looking at but i love the idea of the
picturing of the mythos
by thinking about bodies and material
and i think that's lovely the thing i'm
also struggling and thinking about is
as many of us have visited enough
campuses
tech campuses and then certainly talk
about mit students
also know that that's right
side of them as a knowledge worker
um i think you know
one
these kind of quasi umbrellas because
the fluorescent lights
or the sleeping bags shoved a cubicle
so i'm just curious if you thought about
i mean of course
but there is something materially
embodied quite miserable sometimes about
that those campuses you're going to
blessing it over with the dentist
you know so i just i wondered if that
if that was ever certainly
i would love to photograph in there but
good luck
maybe that's
we were aware foreign that and i i've
often thought that undergraduate life at
mit is perfect for that you know part of
what the undergraduate life at mit is
designed to do is to brutalize young
folks so that they take those conditions
but you know
you know what's a hackathon but you know
at night i didn't spend with my friends
but um we were not so i've gotten into
tech firms but only because i have
friends who work there and i've gone in
on a personal basis and then turned it
into work we were totally unable to get
married there on any kind of formal
photographing basis i made a portrait of
a woman at google and it was yeah you're
right it was like not great in there and
went and she and she retracted it
because when her
higher-ups found out that she let me in
especially if you love the value chain
in their perception inside the firm
the companies become very aware of
reputation issues
and you know very best work is i think
slated to be in our new computer science
building i'm very excited about
um but we are unable to hang banners on
the walls very bad that makes it 40 by
40-foot banners and has done that in
every other project we're unable to do
that at stanford because the buildings
are trademarked
yeah we can't we can't the buildings
themselves they'll lose themselves our
trademark and it would be a brand
violation
just saying
so but that's but that's exactly the
visual regime work i was talking about
earlier you know we're doing work to
make sure that those are not people but
a brand violation like that's
interesting
well i think we
just hit with 6 28. so
thank you should i answer your question
yes yes
thank you for having us heather this is
what comparative media studies is for
you